[Música]
alguna vez fue la capital cultural de
mauritania en el corazón del sahara
durante más de 1000 años la antigua
ciudad de chinguetti ha recibido a los
viajeros que cruzan el desierto mientras
los nómadas y eruditos iban y venían
muchos dejaron atrás algunos remanentes
textos invaluables guardados en
bibliotecas como esta que contiene más
de 7000 manuscritos antiguos
y aquí estamos en mi hogar
esta es la colección de mi familia la
familia al ahmed mahmoud desde 1600 99
seif islam es el orgulloso guardián de
este tesoro más de cuatrocientos
cincuenta libros coleccionados por sus
ancestros
estos libros antiguos fueron dejados por
peregrinos que se dirigían hacia la meca
o fueron traídos de distintos países del
mundo islámico
estos son textos de poesía árabe aquí
tenemos algunos textos científicos sobre
astronomía
y aquí hay un pequeño libro de bolsillo
de viajes y manuscritos que se remontan
a los siglos 12 y 13 que han pasado de
generación en generación nuestros
ancestros habían hacía mucho tiempo que
nuestro planeta era redondo y que giraba
alrededor del sol
mucho antes que copérnico y galileo
gracias a sus docenas de bibliotecas
chinguetti se ha ganado el apodo de la
sorbona del desierto la amenaza
yihadista ha disminuido en la región
durante los últimos diez años pero hay
muchos otros peligros el mayor enemigo
es el tiempo y el abrasador calor del
sahara pero no sólo eso
abdullah ghulam es dueño de una de las
bibliotecas más famosas de la ciudad su
colección de más de 1000 libros escritos
en piel de gacela y con líneas de oro
está siendo devorada por las termitas
este libro fue atacado por las termitas
es un desastre su método de conservación
es sencillo pero efectivo
llenamos los baldes con agua manualmente
y así
la sala habitación no está climatizada
entonces el calor dañan pero estos
baldes de agua humidifica en la
habitación y bajan la temperatura máximo
hasta 35 grados
máximo
[Música]
pero las amenazas también acechan en el
exterior
traídas por los vientos secos las
frecuentes tormentas de arena son una
fuerza de la naturaleza que lentamente
devora las casas una por una
los llevaré hasta el desierto gran
fiesta justo allá mohamed lemine está a
cargo del mantenimiento de la biblioteca
sin embargo para poder entrar
de esta puerta está completamente
enterrada y de abrirse paso primero hay
que sacar toda esta arena para poder
entrar
esta casa se construyó en 1993 y en ese
entonces no había un solo grano de arena
ahora hay una duna aquí que tiene unos
50 centímetros de altura y del otro lado
está prácticamente a nivel del techo de
la casa que tiene 3 metros 50 de altura
mínimo dos filas de árboles como estas
son sembradas para combatir los vientos
arenosos pero no pueden competir contra
la fuerza de la naturaleza
para salvar los manuscritos mohamed
trabaja en la digitalización de los
textos
un delicado y meticuloso proceso con la
dificultad adicional de tener que
persuadir a los dueños para que saquen
los frágiles libros de su refugio pero
mientras la memoria sobrevive más allá
del pergamino las cápsulas del tiempo de
chinguetti siguen resistiendo a la
prueba del tiempo ocultas en pequeñas y
empolvadas cuevas del tesoro en el
desierto